karine béchir gologo professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou
bonjour calmes et chez eux merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france comment est-ce qu'il faut
interpréter ce coup de fil diplomatiques
entre angela merkel et vladimir poutine
qu'est ce que ça peut faire évoluer
concrètement sur le terrain
bonjour j'ai peur que sur le terrain
c'est une fin strictement rien évolué
puisque c'est pas le but de ce genre de
coups de téléphone dans la mesure où
l'allemagne a n'est pas un décideur
l'allemagne est une sorte de
porte-parole en fait donc l'allemagne a
exprimé la position qui était celle des
américains des canadiens et des
britanniques qui avec la lituanie et la
pologne pour courir quand même un peu le
champ européens avaient dit qu'ils
étaient inquiets par la présence
militaire de l'armée rouge en russie
donc c'est quand même un petit peu
absurde
le président ukrainien volodimir dance
qui s'est rendu hier sur le front du
conflit le fait de se déplacer dans ce
n'est un treillis militaire est-ce que
ça laisse penser des prochaines heures
inquiétante ou bien au contraire c'est
un coup de communication ne connais pas
vraiment au final en france la
personnalité du président ukrainien
pour l'instant c'est plus de la
communication a c'est une sorte de jeu à
la guerre en jouant avec les images mais
ce qui est aussi plus inquiétant c'est
la présence en même temps d'une
délégation américaine qui lui perd
également dans le donbass sous la
présidence de l'attaché militaire
américain
et là on peut se demander si à angela
merkel qui est tellement inquiète pour
la désescalade du conflit ne pourrait
pas demandé également aux états unis ch
d'empêcher ce genre de provocation qui
peuvent provoquer une escalade du
conflit
alors justement c'est la prochaine
question à vous
vous enchaînez sur ce que je voulais
vous poser une question à quoi est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre ces prochains
jours simple escalade verbale ou risque
d'embrasement sur le front c'est
difficile à dire puisque si en général
beaucoup sont prêts à gagner un combat
peu sont prêts à se battre en fait en
réalité
donc pour l'instant nous sommes dans une
phase de communication dans une phase
d'escaladé verbale
le problème comme l'avait suis
d'ailleurs le présente en russe le
président russe pendant c'est que
higgins qui ne maîtrise pas du tout le
rôle des à des groupes extrémistes qui
sont de plus en plus impliqué sur la
ligne de front et que le dérapage est
toujours possible parce que si l'armée
ukrainienne attaque d'euros dont basse
met en danger la population locale
les autorités russes ont déclaré
qu'elles ne pourraient pas laisser
massacrer les gens sur place
donc même si elles ne veulent pas porter
atteinte à la paix peut pas porter
atteinte à l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine ils seront obligés
d'intervenir pour défendre des
populations
qu'est ce qu'il reste aujourd'hui
concrètement des accords de paix de
minsk il n'en reste rien parce que dès
le départ ce sont des accords mort-né
vous ne faites pas un accord vous
comptiez pas des accords de paix en
espérant que ça puisse fonctionner
lorsque vous avez des partis qui a non
pas épuiser le combat sur place c'est le
problème si vous voulez de ces méthodes
actuelles de compilation et
d'enchaînements d'accord de paix de
cessez le feu
alors que le conflit militaire n'est pas
épuisé le problème c'est qu'il est
certaine manière ça et vite et c'est
très bien effectivement qu'il ait
beaucoup des morts civiles à un moment
donné mais ça fait dur et les conflits
puisque ça ne permet pas de les résorber
merci thank you love quoi d'avoir
répondu aux questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou
merci